who will be kenya's next leader
president uhuru kenyatta is stepping
down after a decade in power previous
elections were marred by violence will
it be different this time and what's at
stake in this vote this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum kenyans go to the polls on
tuesday to choose a new president
parliament and county assemblies
candidates held their final campaigns
over the weekend drawing large crowds
some familiar faces are vying for the
presidency and their messages are
similar revive the economy create jobs
and end corruption many voters
frustrated by corruption and
skyrocketing prices are calling for
change haru mutasa in nairobi has more
on who is running and what is at stake
this is ugali made from kenyan staple
unga or maismill like most basics here
its price has gone up and because of
shortages it's not easy to find
if things continue this way more
businesses will close
we are facing a lot of challenges
corruption foreign debt rising inflation
and unemployment are big election issues
and all candidates have promised to
cushion households against the
increasing cost of living
four politicians are running for the
presidency
david
a lawyer and pastor
a law professor william ruto kenya's
deputy president and ryla odinga a
former prime minister
but opinion poll suggests there are two
front runners
the current deputy president who
describes himself as a hustler and hopes
his rags to reach his story will
resonate with the poor
and odinga who's making his fifth bid
for the top job the veteran opposition
leader is the son of kenya's first vice
president and enjoys the backing of
current leader uhuru kenyatta
it's an election some analysts say will
be hotly contested kikuyu is the largest
ethnic group in kenya have no
presidential favorites this time however
both ruto and odinga have chosen hikuyu
running mates in a country where ethnic
voting blocks are important a divided
kikuyu vote means this election could go
either way
there are already claims and counter
claims of sabotage and votricking more
than a thousand people died in the 2007
elections what happens with kenya's
geopolitical significance is that it
just that that tension uh sort of begins
to
to shake up the uh uh the stability of
the
of the great horn of africa and the
larger east africa so that's what and
there's a lot of international
organizations that are based here so
kenya is very strategic uh from a global
perspective and that's what the
international community is looking at
the business community is basically just
sitting on the edge of their seats
trying to figure out whether this is
going to go peacefully or not
unlike some previous votes there's been
less pre-election violence kenyans
generally have confidence in the
judiciary many hope if the results are
disputed candidates will resolve their
differences in court and not the streets
haru mutasa al jazeera nairobi
pre and post-election violence in kenya
is rooted in ethnic tensions
every vote since 1997 has been marred by
unrest more than a thousand people were
killed and six hundred thousand
displaced in 2007 when rival candidates
both claimed victory
ten years later dozens of people were
killed when police clamped down on
demonstrations the opposition refused to
accept the results claiming vote rigging
and fraud
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in london is fergus kell a
research analyst in the africa program
at chatham house
and in nairobi is jackie quanique a
lawyer and writer a warm welcome to you
both and thanks so much for joining us
today on inside story jackie let me
start with you today um elections in
kenya are often more about personalities
and ethnic alliances
are issues like the economy the cost of
living and fighting corruption more
front and center for voters this time
than they were in the past
um i'd say yes um because the cost of
living has first reason to an unbearable
rate right now um kenyans
recently had the president um pass a
subsidy
on may's flag yeah a packet of baseball
was retailing for
that would be two dollars on your end
two dollars
and um in kenya we had it was capped at
a dollar because people people the
financial and um
economic sentiments we are suffering we
are struggling
um
yeah that i'd say yes it's taken more
center stage and then for the first time
ever both front the front runners are
not from the main
the the
the tribe that's seen as the main
tribe for
for political leadership
uh fergus how close is the race expected
to be uh is it possible there could be a
runoff and and half the candidates made
commitments to respect the outcome
so i think we are likely to see a close
race i think uh
there are probably three likely
potential outcomes any of which is
possible at this stage that would be
either an outright rylo dingle win an
outright william ruto win in which case
either of the candidates would need to
receive over 50 of the vote but the
third option as you say is a runoff in
which neither of the
main candidates receives 50 of the vote
and that might be possible due to the
two slightly more uh peripheral outsider
candidates david muary
and professor waka joya
and so
it is going to be a tight race polling
suggests that it that it will be close
and it will be about the
the calculus of different regional
strongholds uh and battleground states
as well there and in terms of a
commitment to respect the results i
think uh all the way back in march we
had both candidates uh speak at chatham
house here in london in which they both
pledged to respect
the outcome of a free and fair election
and the uh in more recent weeks in the
last week both have agreed that they
will shake hands or have tea together
after the result is announced and so i
think the important message there is
that
they accept the results of a free and
fair election and if the election is
deemed not to be free and fair that they
challenge that within the proper
judicial framework of the supreme court
jackie i saw you nodding along to some
of what fergus was saying so i'm going
to let you jump in and add whatever
you'd like to add but i also want to ask
you um you know kenya has a recent
history of turbulent elections and and
violence after elections is there a
concern this time that violence could
play a part and and from your
perspective have precautions been taken
to ensure that this doesn't happen
i think um
i'd like first i'd like just like to
commend all the parties so far and how
they've conducted themselves for the
first time in
recent history we've had a violence free
relatively violent free campaign period
normally
during campaign periods in kenya we'll
have many strikes leading after the
election we're used to office closures
people can't access the central business
district this year we've not had any
incidences of that and i think it's
because of some of the commitments that
have been made by
the
the political candidates and um as a
kenyan i'm really grateful for that
we've been able to to work almost all
through the campaign all through the
campaign almost
and that's us nodding along um their
commitment towards um shaking hands
because it's because the general
sentiment of kenyans this time is let's
finish this and let's go back to work
because
truly whatever i'll go back to
constantly because some people are
literally leaving hand to mouth so
that's that's the assertion that
everyone's on
uh jackie you know you were mentioning
just there the importance of this idea
of having a handshake and i actually
want to talk for a second about a
different handshake that made headlines
a few years back uh you know rylo odinga
has run for president four other times
in the past but this time he is backed
by longtime political rival president
uhuru kenyatta and there was this very
famous and public handshake between the
two in 2018 how did the alliance between
these two leaders come about and how
significant is it
and it was significant in that at that
time there was like work work was that
nothing was nothing had gone back to
normal following the election period
because
there are both both sides were just were
disgruntled remember there was a ruling
by the supreme court rather judgment
sorry but the supreme court that
nullified the elections the first time
now and so when we when the second
elections were held um a number of a
number of um the electorate those who
were supporting right now dinga actually
did not were urged to abstain from
voting so already even though we went
through the process a second time the
the number of people who felt like their
issues weren't addressed who did not
even turn up to what
was sizable so
this i think that that handshake was so
that kenya could go on so that we could
be transported people
and i think at that time it was very
crucial he brought peace it brushed
normalcy we needed it
and um
i know there's a lot of criticism around
it
but here i'd be speaking as a kenyan
someone whose daily life had been
affected and would be affected if uh if
it had not been resolved the handshake
was crucial for returning us to know
about the end
and just for government business to go
on for daily business to go on for our
lives to move on because i i noticed we
tend to focus on
the higher stakes in politics and forget
the people who are actually affected
electorate
fergus the alliance between ryla odinga
and uhuru kenyatta basically sidelined
kenyatta's deputy william ruto who is
running
um what led to the fallout between
kenyatta and ruto
it's unclear what the
precise reasons are for the fallout but
there is a general understanding that it
was linked to
a promise or an understanding between
president kenyatta and william ruto that
when they came together in what was
to some extent a marriage of convenience
to contest for the elections in in 2013
and and in 2017 that kenyatta would
repay the favor by supporting ruto uh in
his ca in when he was contesting for the
presidency following the end of
kenyatta's second term
of course with the handshake and with
kenyatta's public backing of odinga and
of the bbi initiative that emerged from
that we have
seen that that promise whether it was
made has not has not been fulfilled and
so ruto
in his own ambitions to
ascend to the presidency
split off from kenyatta distanced
himself from cabinet meetings and ended
up
leaving the party that they formed
together
jackie william ruta describes himself as
a hustler and he has cast this race as a
contest between hustlers and dynasties
so what does he mean when he uses the
term hustler versus when he uses the
term dynasty and and has this framing
device that that ruto is using has it
caught on is it having a big impact uh
in the election uh thus far in the
campaigning
okay um for context our current
president was the son of our founding
president
and reinhard dinger's father philippe
jeramogi
odinga was one of kenya's vice
presidents
so they are considered dynasty by much
of the fact that their fathers have held
positions of power
and uh bruto where um
rather is claiming that he rules from
being the son of a nobody
um to to where he is that he's claiming
he's claiming that he's self-made he's
come up and
that's i guess is his appeal and
how he's trying to be more relatable to
the masses
um for kenyans for those who honestly
because the majority of kenyans live
below the poverty line so if i could get
here you can get here i'm the son of no
one and
very many people can relate to that
message i think it has resonated with
some people
fergus um what are the main issues that
are separating the leading candidates
this time out what what platforms are
they running on
so i would say that there has broadly
been
increasing convergence between the two
candidates on key manifesto issues but
there are a few that separate them to
some extent
one of them i would say is corruption in
that rylo dinger has been campaigning on
a very strong
zero tolerance to corruption platform
that's one of his key
messages throughout the campaign whereas
for furuto that's been less of a feature
of his campaign and he's chosen instead
to emphasize the needs for independence
in the anti-corruption agencies in in
kenya so and the need to de-politicize
the fight against corruption in kenya
there's also on debt there's some
divergence there in terms of uh ruto is
uh is fairly sure that his campaign
promises in broadening the tax base
would allow kenya to tackle its its tax
its uh debt issues whereas odinga has
promised to restructure and renegotiate
some of the debt burden
uh i think there's also a general slight
difference in terms of the the focus of
their campaign so uh odinga's being much
more focused on social protection on
healthcare promises in particular
whereas ruto has a real strong emphasis
on this on his economic model which he
calls bottom up
and on support to entrepreneurs in kenya
jackie uh it does seem that uh
corruption is playing a major role uh in
in the campaign uh season how frustrated
are voters with corruption in kenya and
with this and and and
do any of the the leading candidates
have credibility when it comes to
pledges to to tackle these issues and
fight corruption
um i'd say kenyans are quite frustrated
we have we have on average two to three
major scandals um a year where the
amounts are unthinkable for for noble
kenyans so yes it's frustrating to
to majority of the electorate
i know it's a major issue as we go in
um to the election to into the election
period and um when it comes to both the
candidates
here i mentioned uh as i mentioned it
yesterday i'll repeat it again but many
of the voters are a bit um
hesitant to believe any of the promises
being made because both both both the
leading candidates in this election have
served in previous governments have held
positions of have fun positions of
influence
and
there hasn't been felt to be much
traction or much uh change from from
from them being in those positions so
i think this hesitancy to believe them
and
i think these are greater focus on their
other on their other promises more than
that wasn't corruption
fergus i saw you nodding along to some
of what jackie was saying did you want
to jump in
uh i would i would echo what jackie is
is saying that corruption has probably
been supplanted by uh broader economic
issues as uh as
a key campaigning uh topic in this
election campaign but i i would say that
on your question around uh
the anti-corruption stances of of key
figures that martha carrera the uh
deputy presidential candidate uh on the
honor as part of edingo's campaign is
seen as as someone with reasonable
integrity when it comes uh to the the
anti-corruption
um issue she's popular with civil
society in kenya um as it relates to
this issue
jackie um rylo odinga nominated martha
carua as his running mate she's a
longtime politician former justice
minister she's the first woman to be
nominated as a running mate on a major
political ticket has this choice uh
energized the electorate and has it
given
raila odinga's campaign a boost
i i would say it has because
she's never been seen as a frontrunner
nine times with on the on that on the
presidential platform in on a national
base or whatever
um she's not my she's never managed to
garner that much support by herself
however martha carrera is a force and
and having a woman who has been seen
fighting for different causes um
through the 90s the early 2000s and
2010s she's she's been very instrumental
in a number of things and
i think it has bolstered his campaign
um i think it's won him some confidence
and uh
and i just want to see i don't want to i
don't i'm trying not to go too much into
um
individuals but i i do think it was a
good choice and and jackie um have the
political reforms that were introduced
after the election violence in 2007 have
those political reforms made it easier
for women and even for youth to
participate in the political process
definitely definitely i'd say the new
constitution actually 2010 has made it a
lot a lot easier for women and youth
because um
there's a program called ago under which
women and youth
get 30 percent of government at least
government business contracts 30 percent
reserve women and youth
and i think this has increased access to
capital and funds for for those two
groups the women and the youth and
capital at the end of the day elections
is about money and if they have access
to money then you can move can move can
you can move voters you can you can make
yourself visible so i think this has
greatly changed things and also the one
that generally they're more the more
political offices that women can go for
like every minute that wasn't there
before so
i think that's definitely definitely not
very well in 2007 and um
and i'm wife and i'm happy for that
fergus women make up nearly half of
registered voters in kenya but compared
to other countries in east africa kenya
still has few female elected leaders um
from your perspective why is that and
are there signs that things might play
out differently this election cycle
well i think partly it comes uh back a
little bit to what jackie was saying
just now about the role of money in uh
in kenyan elections i think there had
been a clear effort this time to pass
campaign financing laws that would have
increased transparency and introduced
spending limits for the campaigns
those didn't eventually end up passing
and and so you know
we have seen kind of unchecked spending
by candidates which again does make it
difficult for
slightly more marginalized groups to
enter into the political process i think
as well looking at the number of
candidates who are contesting this time
out of i think around 16 000
uh total candidates only about 12 of
those are actually women so there's
clearly a long way to go on uh on this
front in order to uh to achieve better
gender representation in kind of senior
canyon politics
jackie what about the youth in this
election cycle how invested are they are
are they more uh apathetic are they more
energized and and how much has the use
of social media um changed the campaign
thus far
um i'll say i think there's greater
apathy amongst people who voted
previously the new voters are more
excited i i think they're more plugged
in i recently saw
whoever runs the account is doing a good
job in engaging with
with the youth on it and i can see
some other questions that being are
coming are arising from that
engagement um and um twitter i'll say
twitter has been agreed to for different
candidates to address issues and um
i can't compare the social media
penetration that's there this time to
let's say two thousand
i think to 2017 there was a level of it
but i felt there was a lot of
interference in 2017 2022 feels a lot
more organic
um at least for much i've been able to
witness lately so i am for the youth i
think they're more plugged in they're
asking more questions
they're
i know i've seen a number of skips being
run by gen z on um what it feels like to
be in a presidential debate um
how they doubt they'd respond to
different um issues and i've been quite
impressed just seeing the uptick i think
the first time voters the youth those
are the ones to watch out for i think
they'll they may change everything
fergus kenya is east africa's economic
hub
how important is it to the region that
that during this election and and after
this election things remain calm and
stable
i think it's really significant uh not
just in terms of kenya's economic role
which is obviously significant
especially for the landlocked countries
in the east africa region but also in
terms of the benchmark that would set
for democracy i mean
kenya is the only country in east africa
to have
overseen a relatively stable transition
of power between government and
opposition and when you look at the
current situation
in tanzania or uganda for example where
the context has been really difficult
for opposition parties to operate i
think kenya leading the way in terms of
stable transition is is really important
also when you look for example at the
2017 annulment uh the precedent that
that set for the rest of the region and
internationally was really significant
and we already saw uh in malawi um in
2020 a similar annulment of a
presidential result which cited the 2017
kenya ruling as a precedent so kenya
really has the potential to
to lead on this within the region and to
act as a benchmark
jackie um
from your vantage point there in nairobi
um what's the earliest you think that
official results would be announced
i think friday
all right well it will be very eventful
and interesting to see how it all plays
out in the end uh that's all the time we
have for today so we're going to have to
leave the conversation there thanks so
much to our guests fergus kell and
jackie quanique
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim joham and the whole team
here bye for now